so I guess go into your voice acting I I
saw that you got a role in tomachan
recently where I I think it might be a
first where you voice both the Japanese
character and the English and the
English dub character as well yeah it's
like somebody did it beforehand but uh
it was the first where the English dub
and the Japanese version were streamed
on the same day oh wow yeah usually
there's a gap like several months you
know I must have fun getting to do the
modern language oh it was really I
didn't I didn't get to do that with when
I was on politics yeah that's because
licensing stuff yeah yeah okay I'm just
like what the [__] FUNimation you could
have just called me bro wait I would
have been down to do it I think it
actually takes way more work to be able
to like hire you to do it again yeah
yeah it's like a whole thing yeah did
you have to audition for both the
English dub and the Japanese yeah really
they sent me both the scripts oh wow but
you know how a lot of people don't know
that acting in a different language is
so different yeah just because you can
act in Japanese doesn't mean you can act
in English
so that was my problem I was like I've
never acted in English before Oh okay
because I was like I don't know if I can
do it but I'm gonna send my in my
audition anyway see how they like it and
I somehow got the part though did you
want to voice such in English or was it
something that like your agency was just
like hey you should try dubbing in
English as well that'll be an awesome
experience
um well my agency really didn't say
anything I think it's just a production
team of tomochan as a girl was like it
would be cool if you know Carol the
character that I voiced yeah was voiced
by the same person
which one did you record first was it
the Japanese the Japanese version oh
yeah okay so you got you got like a you
sounded the English session like I don't
know
all right guys I know the character
ain't my first time I don't know if you
know but I voice this character actually
it was actually really uh easy to do in
English at first they were like we need
two weeks like you need to I we recorded
in Texas they told me I needed to be
there for two weeks because you went all
the way to Texas four yeah
um yeah building and they were like this
is your first time dubbing in English so
you probably need two weeks because you
don't you know know the process but I
finished it in less than four days
you just had like a week off in Texas oh
no so it was just one week I was there
like oh all right so you flew background
was there a reason why they didn't want
to do the job here at Japan remotely uh
they said it was because it was my first
time and they wanted okay oh I certainly
like have me experience yeah so how was
how was the like I guess difference
between like you know a Japanese voice
acting session versus an English voice
acting session it was so different first
of all like the Japanese voice acting uh
Studio you're there with majority of the
classes yeah and well once covid hit
it's more like three to four people per
session but still I was there with the
four main cast members so we would just
you know act it out all together but in
the English dub it was just me in one
Studio it was also really small too
right yeah so and uh the lines you have
to say the lines after this like three
beeping noise
so the Japanese version there's like a
30 minute anime there's an A Part and a
b part and like one is like 15 minutes
and you would test the a part like
without stopping and then you would have
like the real thing right it's just like
two takes you know yeah but the English
is like line by line line by line yeah
yeah so that was yeah because with the
Japanese like with the Japanese side did
you have to worry about matching the
lift flaps or was it just kind of just
say the lines and we'll animate the lip
flaps for you it was like say the lines
but in this timing okay yeah they
normally don't care about laptops as
much Japanese yeah yeah I've noticed
sometimes you watch Japanese like anime
and now yeah it just doesn't match at
all there's like a half a second extra
lip flap after they start finish talking
I'm just like what was that yeah it was
English actually very very strict yeah
English uh they have to match the
syllables yeah yeah the Japanese lines
yeah yeah so that was interesting super
tough because you're like this sounds
unnatural and they're like well there's
nothing yeah welcome to dubs
like they decided to use this word in
Japanese it was 15 so it was long yeah
did you get the script beforehand for
the English dub as well I got it oh like
a week before but they told me not to
look at it that much because it's going
to change on the spot yeah yeah so I
kind of like flapped through it Japan
being like we could know so I I had my
first like voice acting experience in
the anime role as well recently and I
just got like Turned Up on the day I
didn't even know it's normal they
normally don't give you the script
before yeah I like I I didn't know this
because I I don't know I turn off on the
day ready to like film like a vlog right
and I'm like so what are we doing today
uh who are my voice acting because I
thought I was just gonna be like voice
acting like background characters or
something like that uh and uh so they
get me in the booth uh they show me the
script and I'm like
Simon names character what the [__] I uh
I die in this scene
I I I got to do some acting acting and
they're like yeah here's the script
here's your lines I'm like I did not get
any prep for this terrifying whatsoever
were they just like we've seen every
bridge we know you could say come on
don't lie don't light off
this vagrant right here this is the guy
we were in a gacha game and it was we
had like very funny lines yeah and gone
just sounded exactly like I just I just
sounded myself
oh it's gone we immediately recognize
this voice yeah
but yeah it was it was the first time
that I had to like not use my YouTube
voice and I actually had to like I guess
wait what kind of voice did you do
oh yeah I'm so interesting yeah I can't
wait to see this Vlog yeah because like
every time like you know even like with
your older Bridge stuff right yeah I
know immediately I'm like oh that's gone
oh it's still me right it's still
definitely me but it's not like hey guys
it's uh
it's I like I I remember okay so I've
seen like the first draft of my Vlog
which is not out by the way it should be
out by the time this episode's out yeah
yeah I voice a character in Marshall uh
oh crap oh hell yeah yeah yeah voice
character in Marshall will get like kill
I'm one of the characters that got
killed spoilers
um and I remember like I I I'm watching
this Vlog back and I do like okay so
we're gonna try the first take of the
line and I didn't even know that we're
just gonna like just jump right into it
yeah didn't really find my voice at all
so I just started reading in my usual
like
voice uh which looking at the Vlog I'm
just like the sounds so [__] bad
and then they're like okay let's uh take
it like three octaves lower right uh and
I'm like oh I've never done a voice like
this something like that and uh
somehow I had like excellent like
directing and I somehow like stumbled
through it and I'm pretty proud of it it
doesn't sound like oh yeah they've done
before good direction helps a lot yeah
good direction does help a lot so
absolutely I kind of like realized the
uh Power of like good directing did you
did you ever have to with any of your
roles like maybe be asked to do like a
different voice or like a different tone
or anything like that yeah there was a
place I went with uh really high-pitched
voice but they were like no we need an
adult lady and I was like oh no like I
practice all my lines in this like kitty
like yeah suddenly I had to be like
an impact is for that and yeah that was
that was hard right right I went home
crying
I feel like you're putting way too much
pressure on yourself yeah
minor life inconvenience
all time
yeah oh my gosh
so how how many other live voice acting
roles have you have you been able to get
more now since you've kind of like
opened the door
um yeah slowly but surely right now I'm
doing uh this character called Katarina
from World dye star we have a game
that's a rhythm game that's already out
we haven't downloaded it yet
but yeah but um a lot of the times the
characters I voice are people who speak
another language as well you know
and it's really hard because sometimes
people would be like oh she only got
that role because she can speak English
you know you mad bro I sometimes I need
English yeah
we've all seen Croco basket when they go
to America it sounds awful yeah they
should have got English people someone
should have got the wrong question yeah
sure sure
you know I think that's just so well
it's like oh you are qualified for the
job it's like oh wow like woe is me that
you have a skill that I don't have yeah
wow it's crazy like I used to get really
down about that being like I guess you
know it's not really my skill it's just
my English but then no it is a skill
yeah but my best friend was like well
you see that girl like she got in
because of her singing that girl got in
because of her appearance like and you
got in because of your English like
what's the difference yeah yeah no take
it with stride wow
you should be prideful of that yeah hell
yeah yeah you have a skill set that not
a lot of people have especially in Japan
and also you can act on top of that as
well if anything you have a skill that I
think a very large proportion of
Japanese people wish they had yeah you
know which is the just being fluent in
English so it's like you know I I mean I
certainly take that with straw whenever
I'm here you know just being like oh wow
you can speak Japanese and English
that's insane and I'm like and in my
head I'm like yeah I mean it's not I'm
not the only one who has that skill but
then when you think about it it's like
no that is a skill that not everybody
can achieve to you know the certain
level so like yeah I think you should be
very proud of the fact that you can
speak both languages yeah we have
generally no skills anything yeah I'm
taking anything I'm like hey so what
what's the game yeah
I know how to edit a video and speak
English that's uh that's my two skill
sets
yeah you kind of just have to I mean I
think a lot a lot of entertainment
personally I find is you'll never have
the perfect skill set or what you need
to always be the best at everything but
it's like how can I currently take what
I have learn more whilst also applying
the current skills that I have into the
situation to the most useful they can be
yeah so it's always just a battle right
of trying to figure that out yeah but
you're in a way more intense environment
if you sit here and chat [__] yeah yeah
this is this we just we just look at a
camera for two hours ago yeah like
that's so hard though because I just
want to announce right now I have never
held a two-hour conversation with
anybody before
like off camera as well off camera as
well like I've never like of course like
you know I've been in a situation where
people are talking for several hours but
I was never part of it you know like I
was just there your managers
like what about the conversations you're
the best buyer yeah
so yeah I was so nervous to because I
was like looking at your podcast and
it's like everything's almost two hours
now I feel even more bad about like okay
literally today Sally just like came in
and we're like all right we're starting
guys sit down don't even like we say hi
and yeah yeah and we're like all right
Sun podcast yeah normally we have like
you know 30 40 minute like just kind of
chat off camera to get to know each
other but we just like sit down right
now we're talking yeah it's like I'm so
used to the Japanese like work ex work
environment I thought I was sitting down
to have like rehearsals or something oh
no no like suddenly trash days baby hi
everybody I'm like oh yeah
starting starting were you laughing or
was that just a oh [__] oh [__] we're
starting I thought my intro was just
really weird I'm like it was weird I was
getting self-conscious